[Music]
[Music]
originally from Texas born in Texas I
was raised in Arizona I got brought to
California by a pimp when I was 18 you
go what bucks California by a pimp when
I was eight hands oh wow but I've been
with the pimps since I was 14
we've been all over Vegas Utah
right Arizona
Washington
here I came here when I was 18 we had
this other girl that came out here with
us from Washington and she lied about
her age and the police when they picked
her up she told him that he forced her
out here and then so he locked him up
and then I got left out here and I know
family my family kindly disowned me
because I chose saying out with black
people
and so like I've been on the streets
since my it's been hard trying to make
it out here how long you been in the
street
I've been in space since I was 14 hmm
yeah
I ended up having kids my daughter when
I met her her dad actually got cleaned
for like two years
and then I stopped prostituting and then
when I had my daughter he started
beating me and stuff and then I had to
leave him so I went back to the streets
and let my babies my boys died recently
had me prostituting when I was pregnant
he didn't give a [ __ ] about me trying to
survive you know had my baby at seven
months pregnant
his brethren I could feel him and I
pregnant again second while
the that brother's wife's best friend
got my other son how many children do
you have
three three do you see any of them I
still my daughter whenever I want but my
two boys are
I wish I could but and and now you're
living on the street here yeah
stay uh no staff no7 yeah right there on
the corner
yeah that's how say that's him
and you're still picking up guys - they
had you know and I got this treat
beating me up last night
what'd he do hit you yeah threw me on
the ground and he was like trying to
drag me on the ground well because um he
[Music]
well yeah it's fun driving
here because he wanted his money back
after what he had his night but he
netted too fast so he wanted his money
back and I was like you can't do that
you can't you know it's not my fault you
came fast you know but
but it's hard out here trying to survive
how much money there's a guy to pay when
he takes you out
typically he gave me $40 for some head
and then because he came too fast it's
like he went in his wing bag and I'm
like yeah the won't work like that he's
still got what she wanted but then I
wasn't gonna give him his money back so
he started to fight it with me and then
he started dragging me and [ __ ] I mean
they defeated all purpose cuz he's still
doing it his money
yeah hmm and what what what's your drug
yen's name is heroin
PCP what age did you start doing drugs
when I started process hitting the pet
got me your Army's doing crack no 13 no
I was fortunate when I started smoking
for yeah other words before 14 to 18 so
at 14 you were working as a prostitute
yes yeah yeah
do talk with your your family your
parents your mom my mom passed away my
dad's a sex offender so I don't talk to
him I don't have another family I'm
gonna my kids tell me about your
childhood
um my dad's it's ha molester my dad
molested me my sister would age he wants
me to feel age of five or six you guys
so my sister from I think from six until
she was 13
where's she now I don't know she ran off
when she was 14
and your mom didn't know this is going
on first
she did but then like she found out
because my sister told her and
my mom didn't believe her and then well
my dad ended up kidnapping me and my
brother took us out of state and when he
had us he has for like six months of
Mexico and then when he were my mom did
get us back my brother and me told her
what he was doing and what he did to me
and stuff and she took me to hot well of
course it's a hospital and stuff yeah he
got put away
for the child
where you like to see yourself in five
years let's just sing myself back in
school having an apartment so I could at
least have my daughter you know who stay
likes with me
better how often you get ran into
violent guys that pick you up
[Music]
oh it just depends really but recently
it's probably been like shitty
like even the police we said they're
making us you know turns date with some
with them and then if we don't return
the day with them releases their ass
again Burnett's he goes to jail and then
of course we give it to him so they let
us go but
make it any better yeah trucks out here
[Music]
well thank you for talking to me and
sharing your story
[Music]
Pyrus I was like everybody else's
good luck out there you say all right
thank you thank you